There is a typo just in the title. There are no CAR-Ts that work yet in AML, but once we get it working, we can profile clones using ctDNA as well.
So Tianzong, I'm here to tell you just a short story about how to use ctDNA to profile MRD and also clonal evolution.
As Vinay mentioned, it is a story in development currently under revision at Cancer Discovery, so hoping to validate this in the near future.
I don't have any conflict of interest for this particular talk today.
So I think this audience understands that AML is really acquired or generated by serial acquisition of somatic mutations or structural variants that starts in the pre-leukemic HIC through the leukemic stem cell and generating frank leukemia with blast greater than 20%.
And there are a lot of therapies being developed reaching almost up to 90%.
Sometimes 100% with the triplets and quadruplets in combination with frontline NHMA.
The overall five-year survival, though, according to the Sears database, is still 30%, and that's including recipients of allotransplant.
And this is really primarily due to loss of CR1, which occurs in greater than up to 60% to 70% of patients even achieving CR1.
And that's still defined by blast.
And that's really primarily due to loss of CR1.
that clinical trials currently